all right so you guys we have Skid Row
in La lots of homeless people everywhere
it's wild I was in New York recently it
was kind of refreshing to not see so
many homeless people but what you guys
have is a lot of [__] just
interesting times on the subway yeah
what is your craziest Subway
story I don't have a cra CRA Subway
story with other people but the craziest
Subway story I could remember is when my
mom was alive and we was on the um train
and my mom got off the train and she
thought I was with her but then the
train closed but then I was like m m
like cuz it was about to go somehow it
like she got it to open again and then I
went oh okay okay it was like yo that
girl almost lost some that girl meet you
at the next stop yeah damn I was scared
as [__] I was I don't know how old I was
I was in New York and I fell asleep on
the train and I woke up in the Bronx I
was supposed to get off like I think
like in Harlem or something where I
asleep the I knocked the [__] out and I
was like oh and then I got off stoping
it was like 2: in the morning it was
really late you could you know what you
could be butt ass naked on a train ain't
nobody going to pay you no mind in New
York cuz you just playing that's true we
don't pay no mind that New Yorkers you
guys mind your business listen New
Yorkers mind yo mind your business yeah
yo almost like it's a good thing but
it's also a bad thing because I've seen
people like getting [__] up and people
just walk by like ain't my problem it's
kind of scary because it's like it's
scary though because it's like a girl
will be getting jumped and nobody nobody
will do nothing they'll record it or
some [__] nobody will do nothing they
just put on wstar yeah put it on wstar
and be like damn why didn't nobody help
so we're going to get a new we're going
to get a new EP in the New Year the
Blick remix coming soon with cardi B um
yo no it's no no it's not no with Dirk
uh you know what I speak it to existence
yeah why not I wish you would just tell
me the state I'd guess it I'm not going
to do once I say the state how about
this tell me the state and then I'll
guess and you can say no can't do it for
you so it's got to be a r Wait wait wait
it's got to be a random random state it
can't it's got to be a really specific
State then cuz if you said New York I'm
not telling you all right you going to
tell me off the camera I'm from a place
where we don't do no
ratting [__] just tell me what happened
M you like that song yeah I love I look
no statements my [__] what you like
better this is New York or no statements
this is New York is my
[__] you know why this is New York makes
me want to like commit a felony and what
does no statements make you want to do
it makes me want to commit a
misdemeanor so the thing about this is
New York is it gives me um it gives me
like when I was uh growing up you know
we had a group group called mop from
Brownsville uh Billy Dan and Lil Fame
and their music made me want to like go
outside and like punch people in the
face and your song this is New York made
me want to like physically assault
somebody for sure so you know like that
song Mak the fact that a song could
really make you want to put hands on
somebody yeah like that's really good
like I mean there's songs that make me
want to sell cocaine shout out to the
clips you know yeah but it's like this
is New York make you want to put hands
on [__] for no reason yeah it's good
workout music you got hey you got some
[__] workout music but no statements
really like but you could work out to
all your [__] like even what the no
statements in the uh and this is this is
New York is like workout [__]
playlist yo how you feel about Blick I
like the Blick record I want to hear I
want to see who's on the
remix who's on a
remix I can't tell you oh we got to wrap
it up you got you got other [__] to do
you're you're you're busy all right
listen EP on the way freestyle go watch
it it's on YouTube too Scarlet I
appreciate you thank you for having me
shout out to Bootleg Kev she didn't
remember my name now I remember you and
that's all that matters that's all that
matters shout out to my man's right here
100 Grand he was with me when I was in a
can understand I wasn't I wasn't there I
don't know shut up
okay here we go